i am a non-stop ball of energy
powerful and full of light
i am a go-getter a difference maker
a leader those are the powerful words
written by one of my favorite children's
authors
derek barnes from his brand new book i
am
every good thing illustrated by the
incredible artist
gordon c james derek and gordon have
made it their mission to feature young
black boys and girls in their stories
and celebrate them to remind readers
that we are all worthy of love and their
message of hope
matters now more than ever it always has
it always
will derek and gordon are you here with
me
hey hi how are you doing drew hi
excellent excellent it sounds good to
hear you read it man
i could i can listen to you read all day
man
it's beautiful well i mean you guys know
crown is
one of my very favorite books in the
world
the thing that you guys do is
you make an empowerment
that feels like a different language
for kids i reading it as an adult
feel like i am feeding my children this
rich beautiful nourishing meal
that is going to set them on a
trajectory of empowerment
that feels not in the ego
but truly in the soul
and do you guys make a conscious effort
of that when you create these books
you know each and every time i sit down
i try to come up with something
that is a universal experience for
everyone but with this project
you know in particular i wanted to
create something that counters
all the negative stereotypes that
exist about black and brown boys in this
country so i wanted to make something
that
we can all relate to no matter where
these babies come from whether they come
from the suburbs or they come from the
projects usa
that there is a a whole group of people
that care about you just as much
as every other parent cares about their
son grandson
nephew that we have high expectations
you know for our sons as well so
this is an offering for black and brown
boys but also for
parents who may not be black
and they have children who have black
friends and
or maybe you don't have any black or
brown boys in your life at all
and i want to counter all those negative
stereotypes and
and just offered this to let them know
that you know we love our babies
and uh we care about them and we want
them to
achieve um the most impossible dreams
that they possibly can
i just wanted to do work where i leave
this legacy that
my my kids would be proud of that my
parents who are sacrificing my
grandparents who came over here from the
islands as immigrants
will be proud like when they made these
sacrifices that they put me in this
position to do this thing
and i'm leaving something good behind in
the world
well i think you make every
young boy and girl and every man and
woman feel like there are possibilities
whirling around inside of us and i think
that you guys
just do it in a way that is
the absolute sort of perfection of that
in fact um i have a little surprise
video for you guys
so you don't have to just take my
opinion for it oh man
derek barnes books make me feel like a
young black king thank you mr bonds
your books make me happy thank you so
much
gordon james for these fantastic
illustrations that really bring the
story to life
thank you derek barnes for another
amazing book it makes me so excited to
see my kids so excited to read your
stories
these are the stories that i wish i had
when i was a kid i like your books
because the characters inspire me
to be confident i liked your book
because some of the characters look like
me and it makes me feel happy
thank you mr gordon for your beautiful
illustrations i love them
we love the ruby booker series she was a
leader and an african-american
so please write the next book you
continue to inspire my children they see
themselves in your work
and i'm so excited for more to come from
you
thank you derek and gordon for making
these books with teamwork they really
inspire me
oh man why you do that to us drew come
on now
but you know we have
a little surprise for you okay
you had written a novel and there were
no illustrations
so uh i curled up with your book for a
little bit
and and we have a little something for
you
oh my god
oh my gosh
oh my gosh i have a a gordon c
james original are you kidding me oh my
gosh look at this
of all the pieces of art i could ever
ever have from derek and gordon it
includes my daughters
thank you that is what means the world
to me
and that is what i love about what you
guys have done
you have found a language a narrative an
illustration a world
that makes children feel worthwhile
thank you guys i
am so grateful that i have an original
piece of art
your pieces of art are museum worthy and
your
your words are that of lyrics and
poetry thank you guys so much i was so
excited
to talk about your very special new book
i
am every good thing and i cannot wait
for the next one please i hope you'll
come celebrate it here with me
thank you thank you for having me